- [Narrator] The
kouign-amann is a specialty
of Northern France. Derived
from the Breton words
for butter and cake, the ratio
for this pastry is special.
It's buttery.
In fact, it's 30 percent
butter and 30 percent sugar.
(mellow, playful music)
Welcome to Douarnenez,
a city with a population
of around 15,000; this small coastal town
has a few main attractions,
including touring the coastlines,
visiting the Port Museum,
and seeing the Chapelle
of Saint-Michel.
(upbeat, playful music)
But that's not why we're here.
We are here to meet Thierry Lucas,
the man to talk to when you want
a truly authentic kouign-amann pastry.
(Thierry speaks in a foreign language)
Legend goes a baker ran
out of goods in their shop
and had to whip up something quickly.
(Thierry speaks in a foreign language)
The pastry has only a
few simple ingredients,
but don't let that fool you.
(upbeat music)
(Thierry speaks in a foreign language)
It's definitely a treat,
probably not something
you'd eat every day.
(Thierry speaks in a foreign language)
Not to have the last word,
but obviously, we tried it.
Bon appetite!
- Bon appetite.
- And I think our face says it all.
And also, this spontaneous remark.
Oh my God, that's so buttery.
(man speaks in foreign language)
- Ten out of 10, would recommend.
Whoa.
(light music)